Darius Rucker three-time Grammy
award-winning country music star we did
have one of those Grammys but he was
told that he needed to have it back in
his possession if he ever thought about
winning another one right that's true
they'd say that they said like to get it
back in my possession a me but that was
a Hootie and the Blowfish Grammy yeah
that was that was like 95 let her cry
yeah yeah absolutely so proud of that
Grammy and all of a sudden somebody from
the Grammys must have watched or
somebody told somebody hey they've got
that Grammy there next thing you know we
need to overnight this they wanted us to
get that Grammy back to them immediately
Darius performs tonight at the world
famous Apollo Theater for the first time
coincides with the release of the new
album when was the last time his fifth
solo country album that drops tomorrow
and will be number one on the charts as
well what do you expect tonight at the
Apollo oh man I don't know you know I've
never played at all show at the Apollo
before I'm like I'm excited do you
change your act because you're playing
at the Apollo yeah I did change that how
do you think countries play it the
Apollo how many actually played there I
don't think there's ever been a country
I could play there there's gonna be a
lot of white people at the Apollo yes
when I was a kid when I was a kid we
didn't talk about playing Madison Square
Garden we talked about playing at the
Apollo no you did and Here I am now
getting to play the Apollo after all
these years of business it's I'm real
nervous I'm excited where's the one
place that that really made that
overwhelmed you was there another place
that uh the first time we played the
garden when we played the Masters when
we played master square guard we'd sold
out two nights in a row and that was WOW
we're playing the friggin card yeah that
was crazy what do people say to you on
the street like in New York oh nobody
sees they'll say anything they don't say
anything
anybody in New York if you say hi they
look like they want to stab you where do
you get aside from South Carolina like
let's say you're walking anyway tonight
anyway anywhere in the rural areas all
over the country like you know I walk
like California or South Dakota I was
walking down the street just gonna get
some food and I think ten people stopped
me walking in South Dakota so you know
any of those rural areas with country
music's pretty big I do people sing your
songs to you they tried but you try you
have to be polite get it done quickly
you know when you get together and I was
wondering about this as you were coming
in when do you know a song is finished
oh when when I get the what's considered
the final mix okay no but when you're
done writing a song like you go okay I'm
done with that song like that now I've
got the period at the end or an
exclamation point it's really when
you're sitting down and you get to that
point to where you know that you you got
a bridge or you're not gonna put a
bridge and you got that's just you know
the songs done and you're finished and
you might edit it again later but you
know it's probably just right when
you're finished when somebody when you
look at each other go yeah that's it but
why it used to be they had to write a
song it had to be three minutes long
that's the way it used to be for radio
play still is but but can you write
everything you want to write in a song
for three minutes
that's hard it's tough and it's country
different though than hootie and the
blowfish where your are you writing for
three minutes where's the Blowfish you
might do something a little bit longer
really did you write this you usually
usually write the song and you hope it's
you know three and a half minutes tops
but then sometimes they're longer and
you just figure if for some single
they'll make it at it I'm gonna leave it
fade it out yeah that's so big I hate
the fader fare like you could still be
sing and they just fade it out exactly
hey I want to get it on the radio good
best ten seconds first ten seconds of a
song you ever heard oh the best opening
ten seconds of a song I've ever heard is
the opening of hey dude it's perfect
it's absolutely perfect why cuz it's
vocal is like you feel that song for the
first time he says hey don't see you're
still trying to do a duet with Paul Paul
you're Proficy which oh my god you see
where Billy Joel's having another kid I
saw that at 60 88 I mean where the kid
goes to high school he's gonna be like
82 a kid's gonna be whooping his butt
and he just sold out how many days and
Rosie played accordion that's crazy I
know when when Prince did the o2 arena I
think he did like 20 consecutive shows
yeah I couldn't do like 20 Canseco Jose
it at the wind jack where's the worst
place she ever did a show oh we played
this place in Birmingham Alabama
he played his place in Birmingham
Birmingham Alabama call the tip-top Club
it was uh and we went on stage it was a
little hole that's not a gentlemen's go
oh what a gentlemen's club it was it was
a band bar and we went in there and we
out numbered everybody it was four of us
and the only people there were the two
bartenders there was nobody else there
and we still play it but it was when did
when did you start to see where all of a
sudden it went from sort of nothing to
everything Oh
around 1990 91 when we started playing
those same clubs and we would we'd show
up and like we showed up a month before
and there was ten people then we show up
now there's a line around the door
around the building you know you knew
something was that then you guys became
big it started to get big at that point
yeah and then you all of a sudden you
could reach out to Dan Marino when did
Dan know who you were when we called him
to be in the news
he's Darius Rucker tonight at the Apollo
at sold out him yes so nobody can get in
they sold out about fifty like two
minutes fifty two minutes yeah three
minutes I think it was yeah wait like
three minutes three minutes again I was
sold out like that the release of the
new album when was the last time your
fifth solo country album Bennett uh is
in stores tomorrow yeah
favorite singer of all time oh good
quests not musician oh boy Luther
Vandross best voice ever oh man he yeah
Luther big old big Luther I won't beg
Luther yeah yeah yeah absolutely man
like sounds like a house not home Cheers
I don't go that way Luther before you
put on a hundred pounds I would still be
with your voice we were bringing this up
to you during the commercial break the
best year or years to be on your tour
bus would have been when definitely the
best stories would go from about about
94 to about 98 the stories that were on
that tour bus were yet so we have a good
time can you give us one with no names
oh goodness gracious oh oh what kind
what kind you want to uh how about we
take a break so we can't do what we're
saying no no no when we do the last show
then we're allowed to you can say
whatever you want to say okay within
reason
I did go on tour with you in Europe yes
yeah we noticed that you got a little
nervous like I'd like to keep my show
think when I was on that tour bus oh man
good times all right we'll take a break
here Darius Rucker joining us he'll be
at the Apollo
coming up tonight for the first time and
when was the last time that's his fifth
solo country album it's released
tomorrow we're back with Darius after
this Dan Patrick show what's the
inspiration for this this record money
[Laughter]
hard is it to write something knowing
like you had a unbelievable first album
with Hootie the Blowfish the pressure
then to come back and know that even in
even country - I mean you've had number
one albums the pressure then to come
back and do another number one album
it's it's crazy especially like with the
first 2d record cuz we have had 10 years
to write that record you know 10 years
and then all of a sudden you have this
big hit you got like three months your
first album is your life yes and then
after that I just have a year or two and
then you got to go back in his studio
yeah that was that that was the toughest
part is that having to do it that quick
but did you write everything mm-hmm but
do you get guys who complain about your
lyrics like is there fighting that goes
on with this no not our group no no no
Ian who D was there no nobody no nobody
said what are you talking about here
there were a couple year band members
who said I you know I'd say to Sony the
drummer I said what is Darius thinking
about hearing he goes I don't know when
you see this if you're watching now on
the big screen that we have in here a
picture of you guys
you know Sony's got hair you have a
little bit of hair I look at that and
all I see is boy we had fun that day
yeah yeah we're look at us man we
hammered
imagine if you were a boyband
like One Direction in these guys who
have this success at that age oh
goodness no cuz how old were you when
you guys I was that at that picture I
was almost 30 20 what imagine being 20 I
couldn't I can't I can't I do like just
playing when we played my early twenties
in little clubs we were playing you know
how crazy that was I can imagine being
as big as we were then at 20 that would
have been I don't know if I'd still be
alive
how you're right how important is it
like you turn a phrase in country music
I mean it feels like that that you play
off of those kind of things and you even
do this with this album when was the
last time you did something for the
first time yeah how important is to try
to find that little hook like that
whether it's a song or an album title
hooks or everything I think for me and
music especially a popular music hooks
they're just everything you got to get
that that phrase or that line or that
melody that makes people want to sing
along and want to you know hear that
again
so the hook sir look sir what music is
all about greatest country song ever
written
oh goodness gracious I don't know the
greatest country song ever written but
the greatest country lion ever written
was uh Johnny Cash a shot a man in Reno
just to watch him die yeah what a great
what a great what a great loss David
Allan Coe had a couple of them too David
some great lives
yeah Paul his line was I was drunk the
day my mom got out of prison yes that's
a yeah that was and I went to pick her
up in the rain food he's been playing
that for 30 years yeah we played that
forever Johnny Cash is underrated as
great as he isn't as greatest people
know he is underrated forever because
what he did when he did it when you do
foot when you go to Folsom Prison and
you're singing to these inmates yeah
yeah I mean he was he was as iconic as
you can be the man in black he was an
amazing songwriter amazing human being I
hear and just a great singer and
yeah I think he wrote the greatest line
in country music history did you ever
play with Tom Petty meet Tom Petty Matt
Tom Petty didn't get to play with him
madam
really that was sad Tom Petty's won
those guys he's so iconic you you
sometimes you don't think about it but
then you go back and you listen oh so
many of them but there's a few of those
guys Bob Seger's and others like that
yes yes seekers like that too and I tell
people and I said this before petit
passed away go out and see him and then
my wife goes you haven't seen him so she
bought me tickets for my birthday I went
to see petty play in Hartford with Joe
Walsh and I want to go see Bob Seger but
I think he may have just postponed his
tour health but I want to go see Bob
Seger's obviously singer too and you
played with John Mellencamp yeah that
was that that was awesome you know
everything everybody says Johnson
curmudgeon you know you know I'd met him
before and we got together he had so
much fun and I was doing an interview
yesterday and there John did this whole
spiel about how much fun you had with me
and and I was just it was so for me
Melik a man you know ain't even done
with the night jack and I and those
songs that were shaping me in high
school and everything and and Here I am
singing whether it was pretty I think I
saw something where Mellencamp somebody
asked Mellencamp about it he goes I
think it was really important to your
dolphins are they have a winning record
Super Bowl Super Bowl Cutler MVP they're
watching it it's so funny I put on
Twitter at the beginning sees a Cutler
MVP and then we go to we go to fourth we
go to L it to London to play New Orleans
and I go to London to this game this is
how crazy I go to the game in London and
we don't score against one of the worst
defenses in the league and all I can
write was okay maybe he's not gonna win
what was it like it when bleeker's
you're singing the anthem and these are
trying times these are the interesting
times where the anthem there any prep
did you feel pressure or did you put
pressure on yourself I
I guess I felt pressure just because
it's amazing to me that all of a sudden
the national anthem which is two and a
half minutes when we all should be
together has become such a dividing rod
right now you know and you know going
over there on foreign soil and doing it
you know you you cuz because I
understand and I live what the you know
the whole protest is about I live it you
know you know I can't tell you how many
times I've been stopped for driving a
nice car you know well you've been out
in front with taking down the
Confederate flag at the Statehouse yeah
you know South Carolina and I get it but
you know just it was a little you know I
called you to talk about it was a little
you know something that that I really
had to think about it and it was uh you
know it's tough it's tough
within these times we're in right now
just tough times well I remember you
saying and I hope you're okay with me
saying it but you're saying you know I
this is I believe in the standing for
the anthemic you know but as a black man
I have to
I also understand what these players are
going absolutely but this is I'm about
the aunt on the Mount of flag yeah so it
had to be that's that's pretty tough and
you're in London doing it and was in the
thing for me is it's not I I get the
protest and I'm glad I'm glad they're
using their platform to protest it
because they're absolutely right like
looking like I was saying you know it's
it's I lived this life I live it I know
it's I live in the south to you know I
know exactly what they're talking about
you I have brothers and cousins and
uncles and and friends and you know that
they've had some really messed up stuff
that's all I've ever been and yet that
concerts that you guys were performing
it
yeah and heard people say things
absolutely you came to the show and you
bought a ticket to the show and you're
yelling at Darius yeah it's it's like
you know I get it
I give it it's got to be tough though it
has always been tough too but I chose
this you know it's been tough to live I
looked at it's been tough to walk into a
room of 15,000 people and you're there
only african-american there that's tough
that's mean and that's happened a lot
it's not I mean it's not a one-time
thing and that's gonna happen tonight
Apollo's gonna say to me tonight you
know this is the most white people
just bring in some Motown that's all you
like the spirits of the Apollo we've got
some good stuff what's your what's your
favorite cover right now my absolute my
favorite cover is no diggity but you've
done that before yeah we've yeah well we
never did with the bullfights we've done
it we did a couple other things no
diggity I started doing the country bad
you never did that with a bluff no I
think I might've did it acapella oh well
but not the band play no oh you didn't
trust him no funky for them I was
bringing this up the other day I was
planning my funeral and I didn't even
think about having you maybe sing but I
was gonna have the Blowfish back
together I just want to know Will
Ferrell's gonna probably give a speech
paulie's producing this and I'm thinking
maybe then I get the Blowfish back
together and you guys could do a couple
of songs absolutely I can really if I
don't go before you yes I'll do that
yeah yeah yeah I wanna I wanna I wanna
the Black Crowes to play descending at
my funeral so there's that well that was
the one song you told me you said you
heard the Black Crowes play it was she
talks to angels she talks to angels and
you said that changed her like all the
sudden you went oh my god Oh change it
changed the way I heard music then I
heard it in a bar I'm gonna sitting at a
bar and I heard she talks to angels and
went are you freaking kidding me
and I went home that night and I wrote
let her cry yeah and why did you let her
cry let me help you that's actually
something one of my favorite moments
Amber's we we play it live for the first
time at the Georgia theatre just a
little this bar in Athens and we play it
live for the first time hadn't even
named it and I'm the show's over and
we're packing up our stuff and this frat
boy comes to the edge of the stage girl
hey man what's the name of that new song
that y'all y'all started but y'all play
we're like well we haven't named it yet
he's like hell man she'll cry after
crime
[Music]
all he did ask you if I had any good
times on the tour bus and I don't know
if I ever had any real fun on the tour
bus I just remember taking you guys down
a couple times
the thing is Dan and I don't you
probably not like this but when we were
younger Dan's felt his job was to show
us that yeah you're rock stars but I can
go a lot harder than it's true you blue
you believe that that's so much we get
together and almost pretty much every
night we were dad at some point I went
okay I'll be right back and they never I
would say weird Darius goes I go he's
got to go to bed trying to do the same
thing they were trying to escape yeah
I'm just trying to bring you guys down
but what I didn't understand is I would
see the Blowfish and they had just been
in Pennsylvania the night before
probably partying and then the night
before that
so everybody who comes out to see them
backstage like hey come on let's hang
out oh yeah then I see yeah my favorite
thing to do is like guys guys go we're
gonna come on the road for a weekend and
this happens every time you know they
get in the bus on Friday and there it's
on you know speed we will paste that
stuff that it's on and sometimes on
Saturday they go y'all I gotta go the
new album it is called when was the you
didn't even sing today I know what do i
what did what happened I don't I don't
know next time I'll sing two songs you
don't have it for the show Wow when we
still live in its feet so yeah now I
have to have Fritchie sing
I love with Fritzie sings
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
he's Darius Rucker at the Apollo tonight
don't even think about getting tickets
but you can buy his new album when was
the last time it's available tomorrow
it's great to see you have fun tonight
Thank You Man
make us proud you're coming out right
I'll say all right Patrick show four
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]